so right here we have a reaction where
you can take some carbon monoxide gas
and some hydrogen gas and when they
react you're going to produce methanol
and this is actually pretty interesting
methanol has many applications one of
them it's actually
race car fuel
but what we're going to do is study how
much methanol we can produce if we have
a certain amount of carbon monoxide and
molecular hydrogen so let's say we have
356 grams of carbon monoxide and 65.0
grams of molecular hydrogen
pause this video and based on this
figure out how many grams of methanol
will we produce
well a good place to start is by
converting these numbers of carbon
monoxide this amount of carbon oxide and
molecular hydrogen into moles and so to
do that we can take out a periodic table
of elements and the molar mass of carbon
monoxide you can look at the molar
masses of carbon and oxygen and add them
together so 12.01 plus 16 that is going
to be
28.01 grams per mole
and if we want to convert to
moles we're going to have to multiply
this times moles
per gram and so for every one mole we
have we just figured it out 28.01
grams and this is going to be
approximately equal to 356 divided by
28.01
is equal to let's see and we have three
significant figures here and four here
so i'll round to 12.7 moles
approximately 12.7
moles and then we could do the same
thing for the molecular hydrogen
and here
we're going for every one mole
how many grams
or what's our molar mass of our
molecular hydrogen
well
each hydrogen atom is
1.008 grams per mole but each molecule
of hydrogen has two hydrogens in it so
it's going to be two times this
so 2.016
2.016 grams per mole or one mole for
every 2.016 grams and so this is going
to be approximately equal to get the
calculator out again
65 divided by 2.016
is equal to
that and we have three significant
figures four significant figures so if i
round to three it's approximately
32.2 moles so 32.2
moles
and so the first thing to think about is
in our reaction for every one mole of
carbon monoxide we use two moles of
molecular hydrogen and then that
produces one mole of methanol right over
here
and so however much carbon monoxide we
have in terms of moles we need twice as
much hydrogen and so we see here
molecular hydrogen and so 2 times 12.7
is going to be 25.4 so we actually have
more than enough molecular hydrogen
and so we are going to use
we are going to use
25.4
moles of molecular hydrogen how did i do
that well it's going to be twice the
number of moles of carbon monoxide twice
this number right over here
is this right over here and we can
immediately see how much we're going to
have left over we're going to have left
over
left over 20 32.2 minus 25.4 is 6.8
6.8
moles of molecular hydrogen and how many
moles of methanol we're going to produce
well the same number of moles of carbon
monoxide that we're using up it's a one
to one ratio so we're going to produce
12.7 moles of methanol
and so let me write that here so if i
have 12.7
moles
of methanol ch3oh
how do i convert this to grams we'll
have to multiply this times a certain
number of grams per mole so that we can
cancel out the moles or essentially the
molar mass of methanol and to figure out
the molar mass of methanol we'll get our
calculator out again
so we have four hydrogens here so 4
times
1.008
is going to be that
and then to that we're going to add
the molar mass of carbon because we have
one carbon plus
12.01 and then plus one oxygen in that
methanol molecule is equal to that and
let's see we will round to the
hundredths place because our oxygen and
carbon molar masses only went to the
hundredths place here so 32.04
32.04 grams per mole so we have 12.7
moles
times 32.04
grams per mole will tell us that we are
going to produce
that much methanol let's say we have
three significant figures four so i'll
round to three so approximately 407
grams of methanol
407 grams of
ch3oh
now the lat next question is what's the
mass of hydrogen that we have left over
well we just have to convert our moles
of hydrogen that we have left over 2
grams
6.8 moles of molecular hydrogen times
the molar mass you're in grams per mole
is just going to be the reciprocal of
this right over here so times
2.016 2.016
is going to give us
this right over here and if we were
rounding to
two significant figures which i have
right over here that is going to give us
approximately 14 grams approximately 14
grams of molecular hydrogen is left over
left
over so we used a good bit of it we used
about 51 grams and we have 14 grams left
over and it was carbon monoxide that was
actually the limiting reactant here